hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
Red Dead Redemption 2 is packed full of
Easter eggs and secrets some secret
items are useful from the day you take
control of Arthur and some are
completely ridiculous but great all the
same here are 15 secret items and unique
pieces of gear to grab on your journey
through a Red Dead Redemption - don't
worry no spoilers here our number 10 is
so damn good you've got to try that one
for yourself let's start with the pirate
hat this beaut can be found on an island
in the flat iron lake just to the left
of Rhodes
be careful swimming over depending on
your stamina you will drown unless you
have a boat try to use the shortest
crossing point or even use the island
above to be doubly sure when in position
you should see a small pirate ship look
inside jumping over to the back you'll
see the hat in all its glory
[Music]
to go full Jacksboro on this journey we
now need a cutlass the pirate sword is
found on yet another island this time in
the southeast corner it's infested with
alligators so watch your step it looks
like our pirate friend didn't make it
far and died in his rowing boat
luckily his sword is there for us to
take our cosplay to the next level
looking damn good a fur
let's see if this effort is worthwhile
[Music]
swords and - cracking against alligators
much better against humans if you're not
a fan of pirates how about something a
little more Halloween inspired there's a
cat mask which can be found in the
swamps of Lemoine by entering this old
Shack you can duck under to the back and
grab this mask from the wall it looks
pretty good but I personally prefer the
pirate hat as it gives me the courage to
fight the Gators Danny I suck at this
game keep heading north by the Kumasi
river and you'll stumble across this
dilapidated fort inside are lots of
items to grab from cigarette cars - this
Civil War knife it's hidden in the
basement of the main cabin
just above the O in Lemoine on the map
is a gang hideout which changes
depending on where you are in the story
get here early enough and you can roll
up on a rival gang and interfere with
their relaxation
in the back room under the bed is a
double action revolver time for another
mask whilst traveling through West
Hanover I was attacked by this motley
crew including Jabba the Hutt playing
the banjo I'm not sure if they are
hostile all the time but once you can
look at the slaughter tent in the middle
of the location here should be a pig
mask for you to wear use Deadeye if you
can't see it there are tons of hatchets
to find in the open world but they
usually look very similar a standout
hatchet can be found in Anne's burg over
by the newly constructed building is a
tree stump go grab the double bit
hatchet for me this place was crawling
with the law it depends where you are in
the game when you roll up and even more
impressive hatchet can be found nearby
travel here to find a Viking alter
Arthur likes to draw things like this so
just let him his inner artist is calling
when he's done jump down to the pile of
bones next to the altar there should be
a freaking Viking hatchet embedded in a
skull to make this location even better
grow your beard and find the Viking
helmet in the tunnel close by
[Music]
it's like watching god of war boy boy up
in the north of the grizzlies is a
ravine to follow up top you'll find an
ancient tomahawk in a target that target
is important because this bad boy is
throwable honestly it's so much fun to
use comes down the best weapon in the
game for me but remember you have to go
and pick it up after every single throw
you don't want to lose that beast up by
Window Rock the train line passes a
waterfall behind that waterfall is a
secret
this is the Nevada hats the not nearby
tells us that this hat was formerly the
property of legendary star of the stage
Robert Elliott Patchen who also can be
found on one of the cigarette cards in
the game let's grab another weapon from
another strange scene just south of the
Grizzlies in West Elizabeth it's
possible to find a woman and a bear in a
warm embrace of course this isn't a
loving the two died in battle
take out the antler knife from the bear
and admire the beautiful face underneath
him still in West Elizabeth is a mind to
be discovered
the problem is it's blocked luckily some
kind soul has already prepped explosives
and all you need to do is push the
plunger grab your Lantern to navigate
the darkness and find yet another person
stabbed to death and the knife is still
there for your collection
another weird our site to visit in Red
Dead Redemption 2 is the pagan ritual
over in the westernmost part of West
Elizabeth Arthur once again can't resist
drawing horror scenes the mad man well
that pagan ritual skull mask can be your
horse and another gorgeous face
underneath now come on look at that that
if that's not a badass cowboy I don't
know what a badass cowboy is and finally
you can get your hands on a Schofield
pistol down in Valentine by simply being
aware of your surroundings there's a
locked door behind the doctor's which
holds a secret looking through the back
window shows as a bookkeeper we can rob
to get in that back room we must first
threaten the doctor until he convinces
those inside to open up sir please you
don't want to get involved with them I
promise you be careful they will attempt
to kill you
so don't get stuck like I did
[Music]
oh the sweet innocent girl yes she'll
try and murder you to have no mercy in
the back room you'll find consumables
money and that pistol you'll definitely
need it because you have to escape next
so there we go
15 unique secret items to grab during
your playthrough of Red Dead Redemption
- there's so many my found but they'd
include spoilers so I've left them out
of this video I'm Adam from Playstation
grenades I bloody love this game I'm
going back to cosplay as Captain Jack
Sparrow with a tomahawk this time I'll
see you next time
[Music]